all right Louis Lewis where'd you grow
up were you worried from my name is
Louis I grew up in Compton California I
tell you about your family you grew up
with both your parents how girl put up
for the first part of my life a group of
both my parents my mother was kind of a
little off in the brain kind of timid
but very good-looking my dad was a real
smart dude he had a real good job as
engineer and now he also had a pool hall
business on the side fact he had a
couple of my granddad had one to
Araucana where they were smart in the
books and his smart on the street also I
grew up with a little child he had four
the fourth citizen at first told my dad
had about 30 kids we were the four that
my mother had how many kids my father
had about 30 kids eat under he I nobody
in my father had about 30 kids from 38
for women or my mother had four of them
so they would they would they would they
would they would fight all the time and
he's he's trauma timing to this day I
don't I don't know I don't like to see a
woman I would think that I wouldn't like
to see a man hit a woman and I grew up
attending any of the story being the
same way because I'm happy - shut up him
something I mean I beat the [ __ ] [ __ ]
up sometime and I cry after I do it
because I don't know why I do it but I'm
gonna think back when about the stuff
that I should do it makes me you know
you can make it makes me rage rage so
anyway I've started growing up and when
I started to grow up I I went to I went
I went I went to I was always called the
punk to square the [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] I was always the square is this
just a punk kid nobody be liked and I
was ugly and what glasses and people
just didn't like me you know now so I
grew up inside just being hurt and just
been incredibly
ain't angry inside in any and every
morning and I thought I hate the way I
looked ahead of where I was ahead of my
family well you you know anyway we grew
up we moved to up to a tool tool to a
bigger city in in in Brentwood and when
we got there my name either really got
bad with my mom he really started being
my mom but if you if you looked at the
outside of house we had a brand-new we
always had brand-new we even had a we
had a we had a we had a 911 Porsche in
Israel you know but if if you went in
the house my dad had guns on her on the
house I'm
they had had had had not full of her
head and stuff what my dad just used to
you used to beat her and the rest of the
kids were complaining all this town
stuff
I remember my mother caught wanted to
put police chasing the confidence get
the police and the police a little weak
she lit a look at my mama my mother said
it was black eyes and then they said
they couldn't do them for he I hated the
[ __ ] police I hated I hated the
[ __ ] police in Stan it wouldn't help
my mother so I grew up and I remember
seeing run I remember I remember when
they're going in I remember I remember
thinking about taking the knife and
going in and stabbing - shut up my daddy
beat my mom when I wanted to take a
knife and just stabbed his mother
[ __ ] that I want to kill that
[ __ ] different thing on his
phone just going in and blow it [ __ ]
head off so one day he he had a bar seat
he had his guns in the joy when I
wouldn't took one of those [ __ ] guns
and he was he was jumping on my mother I
took the [ __ ] gun out didn't know
what I was doing with it I went to go
shoot his [ __ ] ass the some
kind was something hit my hand in the
[ __ ] gun went off wow he decided to
decide the roof for the house that the
police came that's my first time going
to jail and Here I am nine years old and
ten years older they tryna they tryin to
try to get they say I was they tried
they said I try to attempt a I tried to
kill my father but I really didn't try
to kill my father so they put me in this
this when they put me back in school
they put me like a it was in a charter
school back then I was like a remedial
school remedial class for problem
students and I never would talk I never
would talk I never ever would talk I
remember my mother said that they put me
they put me she would come to school to
see what I was doing I was standing in a
corner all by myself you know you should
call me oh my god I til I got over they
start calling me Jason I was always I
would I never smiled I never looked but
I wanted I wanted to kill everybody
I hated everybody I would kill everybody
and I was visible inside about
everything everyone in my life doing
people my life they stuck to my mother
Pete my life that I love live with my
grandma's and they started to die I
really went crazy because I feel like I
didn't have no body you know because my
dad didn't want to do with me he thought
I was sorry he told my stupid told me to
else tell me I was stupid I was dumb I
was worthless no one's gonna ever be
nothing I didn't see it that way
I was even when we moved on it will
remove got a complan moved into this
like this white neighborhood and I
noticed I started I started hanging with
the white guys all started I started to
start two one two one two one two black
girls because when I was going to school
in Compton the kids would take
one get the citizens tried to cut my ear
off another K they would catch me then
we take around the bill and they would
beat me up and stuff like that call me a
[ __ ] but when I got to the to the we
said whiter whiter than a burr hood
schools the white kids didn't do it they
accepted me they can accept me in any
house and everything so that I literally
wanted to be white I wanted I wanna I
wanna I wanna be like back in there I
wanna be like Michael said I wanted I
wanted I wanted to paint my skin white I
hated being black
I hated being I hated the word [ __ ]
fit to me to wear [ __ ] fit Black's just
right I just I would I just felt like I
was I wasn't wondering I was one of them
[ __ ] I was different I even
thought in my head I mean my grandmother
said one time she said she said never I
never I never known a [ __ ] in my life
wanted to be white like Donald Donald my
grandson wants to be a white boy and I
did cuz I hated black I hated [ __ ]
black people so I grew up and remember I
remember when I remember I went out what
now but I was brows I was I was still
real so I was scary I was Rosa I was I
was I was always scared to fight I don't
know I was just scared to fight so I
remember I remember I remember my first
girlfriend she she slapped me in the
face like a [ __ ] ah I like you man with
your pump you never yell you never
cussed you don't call me a [ __ ] you
what's wrong with you you just a [ __ ]
pasquese slap me again policies that I'm
again they're not turning and turned
into [ __ ] I like a like a like a
something something came onto me and I
kind of when I i remember we we took we
took her friend to to go to school in
and we was like a balcony I remember I
took her by the neck
and I and I had it [ __ ] by her [ __ ]
neck I said [ __ ] what you say you
[ __ ] [ __ ] what did you say remember
she was real I see Anna Marie she turned
her face to a rope with her eyes like
greener I started to turn green I'm
really talking about this kind of trauma
too but I didn't kill her but I mean I
almost go so there was one more time I
was going to jump but simply tips
attempt to murder you know my mama hold
my aweful got me on that one didn't they
started assuming his psychologist I want
to psychologist and he's like I'm there
always had bad eyes but I had good ears
I remember I heard overheard the
psychologist saying you better watch him
with you you're somebody say out of the
thing did you want you own this guy's
gonna be some kind of Cyril this guy's
some kind of serial rapist-murderer or
something like this and I heard that
[ __ ] you know any when I went to school
I started I went school up and remember
they always had me in a remedial class
you know the classic word weather where
the teachers in you wouldn't windy I
remember one of my friends amen s Don
Juan he goes to the heat he goes he goes
to the to the nut room they stood in
that room the net classic because I
always went to remedial classes so so
big Lou like me so then when I got to
when I got to the day when I got to the
to the to the to the fifth grade a
friend of mine named Joey well he was in
my free would always beat me up he was
grabbed me by the neck and taking it
down the street he would say we don't we
don't we'll go steal pieces we're gonna
take it we gonna steal pieces and you
know I was so scared of him and remember
this this big girl named Linda said oh
I'll Lois you gonna let him Punk you
like that a minute my first time I got I
got some balls I told him I said you're
not gonna Punk me for an old girl so I
picked up we we're down on on the
baseball corner I took a baseball bat
and I went up sided [ __ ] head then
when I hit him in the head and remember
I thought I remember seeing two knots on
the side of [ __ ] here and when he hit
the ground
or some convulsion and I guy I kind of
like that [ __ ] you know I kind of like
this something now named me I kind of
like this damn I should did I should do
more [ __ ] like tech to anywhere
so as I got older I started to I just I
just thought I just thought it I started
smashing bulging and you know I'm a mom
I threw a dog at the car when it when
the car was going down the street one
day you know what I remember I didn't
wanna I remember I remember we were of
course about right one time in a [ __ ]
horse went to jump over he jumped over
the with jungle or something we jumped
to hit my legs his legs caught the thing
he fell down I remember I remember I
remember beating the horse stuff I mean
I mean anyway they and they got that was
in a little town called probably texting
when they held me down the boys had to
hold me down and they said they said
that the look the look on my face was
like Evel was like [ __ ] even when I
remember the horsemen
oh boy the more he hollered the more
[ __ ] liked it the more I [ __ ]
liked it soon as I got older I remember
they molest him they [ __ ] him
molesting me the babysitter down the
street
[ __ ] molesting me [ __ ] molesting
me the [ __ ] up thing about this [ __ ]
because I liked it I liked it but
because a little kid I couldn't tell
nobody I couldn't turn about his lady
down the street was making me put my
face between her legs I couldn't turn
about her lay down if she was more
sucking on my dick every damn night
every other night when she comes she
come on you don't have to pay me because
she was once in some kind of way it was
weasel do some crazy [ __ ] no so one day
I thought I was gonna be sick I wanted
to go next door so I took her in the
background I'm doing dinner growing a
bad guy next thing I know here come the
[ __ ] company PD what are you doing
how am i I must have been 14 13 or 14 so
I'm down and for that I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm doing exactly with this
girl man does it come before the girls
on the age to go to cross you my name is
9 years old
they got me frown I want to go for that
jail for that then I went on time first
time this time kind of went on I got
older and I never I never would never I
know what never I never I never was
socialist partying cards it's just like
that remember my cousin said hey man
take a shot of this take a second
trigger this year to take a hit this
[ __ ] and everything is gonna be alright
I took that shot of their gene and I
remember playing I remember playing they
teach me how to play cards on how to
play Spain and I'm not a social I never
was I never had I never had backed up I
never had friends never had friends I
don't want nobody you ever heard of I
invited back in the day nobody knows my
name nobody knew my name
no I knew what noon anything about
because I don't know I would say I want
to do is sit up and I wanted to crack
your [ __ ] head I wanted to run you
over with a car I wanted it to do to to
to to [ __ ] your wife how long how long
what I want to do your girlfriend maybe
your daughter something up for me [ __ ]
crazy
this world mileage one when I be licking
the show but look at the innocent little
kid I look at innocent nobody really
knew I was a [ __ ] I was a mess I was
a wreck I was a wreck so my mines get
these bosses crazy [ __ ] my
so finding when I got back to back to
the card game I learned how to play
cards and when he told me how to do it
he taught me how to dream they taught me
how to drink gin I'm drinking gin I
remember I drank the gin until I threw
up I threw up all over the girls floor
and they cleaned it up in the first
thing I said after that I remember the
ceilings and [ __ ] was going around and
the first thing I said no I was out
calling from the [ __ ] start
they put a joint in my mouth a man hit
the [ __ ] joint
I hit the [ __ ] joint I saw stars
oh-ho-ho he went all the way around I
didn't I didn't have to think about me
molester than one have think about less
than one and think about killing nobody
don't work because I was I was I was I
was free you know I was freed in I got a
good job I guess what scar I was running
around but I was still drinking I was
still using then who comes today we were
all at this one house in in Torrance
Torrance California and the girls said
they were all smoking crack back then it
was called rock in Compton I wanted a
little ice skater I wanted to get the
little ice no she took you smoking she
said well you wanna do something you
gotta hit this I don't want to hit that
[ __ ] what the hell are you guys doing
they got a glass privy to put the show
her 5:00 this morning [ __ ] I hate to see
a bell ring everybody had to get out of
house I'm uh I'm all alone now got my
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everything that's crack
now I'm talking about this happy [ __ ]
30 30 35 years ago
that [ __ ] been my best friend
ever since that [ __ ] been
telling me what to do telling me how to
do it making me lose everything in my
life and gaining it back I've been to
rehab I know I've been to 50 rehabs I
can quote the big book I go to the Bible
how much did that [ __ ] do I live none of
it so what made me end up coming
downtown
I had a heart I had head I had a pretty
good yeah I had a pretty good job at
real good hours drive a matter of fact
how to drop up for Southern Pacific just
switching tracks and every now and then
driving the Train you had a real good
job I [ __ ] it off cuz they pissed at
me I had a good real good job they
wanted to put me on a truck one they put
him on the 18-wheeler swimming all over
the country I got you dead folk for four
minutes and they're pissing kissing
dirty on that tonight end up stopping
lying and then I had I had a really good
job I what I really do good is out his
eye his eyes I paint well I was up in
Hollywood painting on the independent
painting
friend of mine lost mine yeah I had some
nice cars
I got my car stolen I got beat up I got
shot I was on seven Street went I'm
walking down the street on a Sunday
afternoon when a guy pull up in the car
I have no idea he looked at me and he
shot bah bah bah bah bah bah I got one
in the leg I got one in a handy guy one
here one here and I got three in the
back about three in the back I stealing
this stops me on crack ice-t let's go
smoke crack anyway I ended up down here
two years ago I was down here was
pouring down [ __ ] rain pouring down
[ __ ] me I didn't know what is day I
said God whoever you are whoever you are
if you exist if it was just forgive me
all the crazy stupid [ __ ] that I did or
a creep I can profess everything about
the girls about the guys about the guns
about the shooting about the killing
about the chickens but the animals are
killed what people I stomped out about
the poor girl I ran out with the car
about the hope I had right
I had three married women had three
million women one one one and it went
one today when are they their husbands
caught me caught me and her in his truck
one day and I think that's when I knew
was a guy cuz when that guy pulled us
over their car he said what the [ __ ] you
doing in my wife's car and I remember he
was on this side of the car and I was on
this side and she liked him she said
this is my friend my cousin he said
[ __ ] you know I'm and he says Amen get
out my [ __ ] car and then they'd
mind you this guy he had a nickname Mike
Tyson he looked like and he's built like
a gorilla he came to the car he says hey
man get the [ __ ] out of my car now I
grabbed the handle on the dough to get
out - god damn car this part of my body
was but my legs said we ain't going no
[ __ ] with him I was so scared my legs
was shaking like just I couldn't get out
to calm my come on I couldn't get out
the car there's a big brand on the other
side good car and he said you look how
my boy every see my wife again
[ __ ] okay mr. Lewis I'm on King
I'm a kid so I couldn't mess with that
girl I was staying in Texas I came home
I was so scared that do live to this day
that happened 13 14 years ago to the day
I'm still scared here on upon me one day
because he you know
banging his whitening is white was
banging she was buying me he bought me a
car she bought me clothes she bought me
everything she just bought me everything
she wanted it she want to get a house of
me so anyway we still tried to get
together but he would caught on the
phone he's caught on the phone with that
[ __ ] are you with there
[ __ ]
are you with that [ __ ] off so
anymore I quit doing it sooner
back-to-back to get getting closer back
to to being it did at the Power Man I
asked God to forgive me for all that
stuff that I did all that demoralizing
incompetent although the mother stations
and all that [ __ ] I went through and all
the crazy [ __ ] new eyes in the forgive
me I said god help me get some [ __ ]
Wednesday if you if you if you real if
you [ __ ] real this what you won't
[ __ ] do by the we later Trump came in
town with the helicopter he looked
somebody said he looked down and said I
wanna know why all these people are down
here and it's good but why all these
people I know you guys said I know
California y'all don't like me but I
give you enough money that you get
better my people he called that he calls
us the people here it is the everybody
talk about down sir now jump talked
about talk he's he spoke for me he said
I give my people enough money you I'm
going to give my people they told they
don't have to live like this I'm gonna
send scouts so when he said Scouts I
went to church that day and the guy said
if you want to play stay coming here
with your paperwork I had a place in two
days
most people come and have five and six
years I get a place that means that if
somebody's doing something wrong with
the [ __ ] money and it was it was
[ __ ] Donald Trump got me on
[ __ ] face
thanks a lot Trump [ __ ] what they said
about you I'm bumper your [ __ ]
heads again I mean anyway that's I ended
up down here so now I'm killed kind of
moonlight you know I'm relapsing every
now and then doing this [ __ ] I'm lonely
as [ __ ] I ain't got no girl you know I'm
due to my hand a lot but hey that's cool
too you know what it's a big it's a big
they don't you do this is you - I'm Luis
Manny I'm out
so let me ask you a question or two this
so the the behavior all the crazy stuff
you just laid out mmm
there's a lot more of I just can't
there's a lot lot is so much do you
think that came from seeing your that
that kind of behavior and your dad oh
yes yeah tell me about your dad and his
relationship with you and your siblings
he's a mean [ __ ] you mean smart
his mother [ __ ] this [ __ ] was so
smart but he doesn't mean [ __ ] what
beat your ass whooped your ass and knock
you out of her [ __ ] heartbeat
how do you treat your sisters he treated
him I don't know maybe he was messed
with a lot maybe a D maybe this bottle
and maybe he's messed with my room but I
don't know but I know he pleased to beat
the [ __ ] out of me beat the [ __ ] out of
my buzz and beat the [ __ ] out of him
mm-hmm he was uh just a mean
[ __ ] he's not watches anymore
god bless him I loving it everything I
miss him sometimes sometime I don't
sometime I say [ __ ]
yes need to be going on the [ __ ]
dirty old [ __ ] hand it you're
welcome
you